This is a quick demonstration of how to easily
select a chromosome region while using NCBI's
Genome Data Viewer, GDV.
I'll start on the GDV home page, with human
selected, but this capability is available
for all organisms that have completely assembled
chromosomes.
I'll open the viewer's display by clicking
on Browse genome, for the latest Assembly,
GRCh38.
By default, all of chr 1 is displayed.
You can change chromosomes in the Ideogram
View,
or in the pull-down menu above the Chromosome
Region Selector, which is the focus of this
video.
And, if you suddenly remember that you really
wanted the previous assembly, you can change
that here as well.
For a few organisms you'll see this cytogenetic
banding.
If you want to view the q24 region, for example,
simply click inside the region to select it,
and the display below zooms to that region.
Of course you can click and drag to select
any part of the chromosome.
Then click and drag the ends of the selection
window to resize it.
For organisms curated by the Genome Reference
Consortium, human, mouse, zebrafish and chicken,
curation regions like patches are annotated
under the chromosome.
Hover over a marked region to get more information.
Then, in the popup, you can click on the Region
name to zoom to that region.
If you click on the RefSeq for this patch,
the graphical view opens that patch scaffold,
this NW_003871055.3 accession.
Clicking on the GenBank accession would open
that record in another browser window.
This tool also presents green arrowheads for
search results.
For example, a search for diabetes finds two
genes on chr1.
If you want to remove those green arrowheads,
use Reset All, near the top of the page.
And don't forget other useful actions.
You can share the view you've created with
the "Share this page" link;
you can download a PDF or SVG file from the
Download menu;
and we'd love to have your feedback and questions.